hey guys i just watched this video and
trust me you're going to want to stick
around till the end
also a reminder if you follow us on
instagram you can guess who the mole
is and we put the poll results in the
video enjoy the episode and remember to
vote
how can you tell if someone is an
american through their knowledge of
american history and political views
maybe it's by the type of food they eat
is it through their consumption of
american pop culture and sports
or is it just by how they look
we brought together seven americans i am
an american
i'm an american i'm an american i'm an
american i
am an american i'm an american i am an
american
one is a liar if the group discovers who
the liar is they'll win a cash prize
if the liar survives they win the cash
prize oh
and by american we're specifically
talking about u.s citizens on this
episode
this is odd man out
so something that makes me an american
is i believe america is one of the
greatest countries in the world
i'm american but by name only
i was born in hawaii so being american
is like a totally different context to
say white cisgendered and lives in ohio
i was born in america
i've always lived in america and i love
my freedoms
lived here all my life i've just lived
the stereotypical american experience
well what makes me american is i'm
really into spots
the lakers there is
no one definition of what an american is
i don't know why i'm so nervous
i'd say i'm pretty confident i'm ready
to win i want i want the money
i'm gonna type out h asl let's
do it nice and simple nice and sweet
these guys where was everyone born that
was my first question
and alex is only 18. there's another
person born from hawaii he also has
the same vote uh like mask on his emoji
so i might like i think maybe later i'm
gonna like be like okay
maybe what are some hawaii things you
grew up
with so that would be interesting i
guess i don't know
naturalize as a baby at six weeks old is
that even a can you be naturalized to
the baby she's adopted
she just said that that's everyone's
favorite thing
oh it's a good one
i actually had that for lunch today too
oh internet is very american these are
all really american
chains they know they're they know their
stuff huh buffalo wild ones yeah so
they're asking oh glenn's parents are
from nigeria
my parents are actually from nigeria ooh
someone
someone's going after glenn alex there
we go 30 seconds left
because this is stuff so if they moved
after then you know who knows
these rounds are so short maybe i'll go
for
glenn just because someone else is him
okay well it seems like everyone is
american so there's actually another
person who's from hawaii
i think sean we kind of click because
we're both from hawaii hopefully he
doesn't vote for me
tim is kind of on my list to be like uh
i mean only vibe i'm getting right now
is from alex that's coming from me so
that kind of
got me like a little bit anxious
[Music]
oh and who am i gonna vote for this
round oh i'm probably gonna vote for
alex
i think i might vote out glenn for this
round
sophia because she was naturalized in
six weeks
sorry glenn it just can't be me
i think i'm gonna vote for tim i'm gonna
vote for glenn
i don't to vote for glenn but i think
that's what i'm going to go for just
because i think some other people were
gunning for him
the person eliminated this round is
here goes yes
i'm sorry i'm pretty sorry i'm i'm
really sorry but i'm glad it wasn't me
i i knew the nigerian stuff took me out
oh so
round two this is the american meme
round
so you will have four minutes to search
the internet for the best american
meme you can find oh my god yes i'm
gonna check
tumblr your time starts
now i love memes so i feel like i'll be
good at it
oh not trump that's too obvious i gotta
find something that'll
impress people i feel like all the news
on google are old like i don't wanna
i don't i don't want them to think that
i'm thinking like okay i think i'm
to go with turducken
wait where'd it go let's start
with sean huh i feel like sean's name is
stupid
oh it's a turkey duck chicken
all right let's see what you got me uh
employee disagrees karen oh god
you did okay that's a good one that's a
really good one
although i wouldn't say karen is like
strictly american
that was good that was good mila what's
the male version of karen is it keith
next up is tim we're getting real
okay cool people people are liking it
okay i was a little worried
okay what can i say about this meme
though i don't know these memes are not
it's a little dry you know oh i didn't
mean to put this in a political thing i
thought it was funny though
[Music]
that jokes are my specialty
okay this is a touchy subject
are you afraid of white people becoming
a minority
why are minorities created like second
class citizens or something
bruh shots fired i hope it was good
enough
sean sucked so country has
did someone order freedom that one's
pretty good too i mean that's pretty
american
it's a stereotype uh
it's not funny that's the thing like
come on we all have funny ones like
the indigenous people that must be tough
oh
deep oh my goodness
oh no who am i going to vote for i
really enjoyed this round um
the memes were all right they weren't as
funny they just made me kind of sad not
gonna lie
so the meme that i chose i tried to
choose something that is
like unequivocally without us
a doubt american who's had a turducken i
mean i could eliminate him just based
off his bad knee
i think i might go with mila she was
very quiet this round
shawn i don't know i kind of feel like
this guy alex
he's kind of a caricature i'm not
convinced
sean i'm gonna vote for sean i'm gonna
vote for alex actually
last minute change last minute change
i'm voting for alex i think
i'm gonna vote for sean because a
turducken
is also canadian i'm voting for sean
sorry sean it just can't be me so the
votes are in
and the person eliminated this round
is sean yes sean
this is going exactly how i wanted to
i'm actually kind of shocked to be
honest i
don't know what i could have done
differently
damn you guys you guys eliminated an
american what is wrong with you
[Music]
hey everyone hi what are you guys
favorite things about being american i
guess
i mean my favorite thing is probably you
know the freedom that we have
um yeah i'm a very like big um first
amendment person so
that's good yeah i i
wouldn't say i'm very happy to be an
american
to be honest and i i actually know a lot
of americans also feel this way
that it's like it's where i was born
it's where i was raised but uh i have no
real attachment
it doesn't feel like home
i'm a libertarian so i'm super into the
first amendment
and pretty much most of them um
so freedom is the big thing but as a
libertarian right
now is terrible oh freedoms are being
stripped dude and
i think people don't get this but
libertarians do not like cops
like we're not just right wingers or
something we do not like cops
hmm i feel like because i'm adopted
like i was growing up like and i wanted
to fit into that thing like all my
friends growing up are white like there
was no
diversity in my little town i can sort
of relate to that i'm not adopted but i
grew up in a very white area
and so i can relate to wanting to
conform to something that
you think is the ideal american and then
when you get older you kind of realize
there is no one definition
of being an american and i agree with
you there uh because like we're
obviously not perfect right now
um but yeah like you're saying like we
can definitely work towards things and
that's like the one of the cool things
that i
enjoy about being american too is that
we have the ability to change things
like that as well
i have families with ties and like the
black panthers and everything
and i was never really i wasn't taught
to be proud to be american i mean it is
what it is i feel like as americans we
should probably be proud of being
ourselves first
is anything of course the individuality
and we're all different
and yeah is everyone registered to vote
yes
so north dakota actually doesn't require
you to register actually
wow i know step
forward i haven't voted yet because i
just turned 18
but uh definitely going to vote
important election
[Music]
i honestly have no idea who is not
american in this group
if anything it uh they think it's a
little harder
felt like we're still trying to feel
each other out
i think i'm gonna vote for um sophia
surely because she didn't talk as much i
think i'm just gonna vote for alex
because he's the most aggressive tim
this round i think i'm gonna vote for
alex because he seems like the most
likely
to be the mole to me i think i'm gonna
have to go with lynn
actually i just asked if i could change
my vote i feel bad
but i feel like she didn't give a lot of
information in the beginning
i think i'm gonna vote for sophia this
round i still got my eyes on you mila
but i'm thinking in sofia so
the votes are in and the person
eliminated this round
is sophia no
wow i'm really worried that i played
myself with my vote like
if i had kept it with alex like would he
have had other votes
they just knew they just knew that i was
american so they had to vote me out
cool hey guys again i have a question
i have a question alex were you the one
that knew the turducken
was from canada um
yeah because i have a lot of canadian
friends and they always went back to
their homes to do turducken
but i've never had a thanksgiving with
turducken we just do turkey i've heard
that
like people in america do but i think
it's more north
near you know near canada i'm guessing
i've only been to canada once
so i don't have that much information on
it but yeah how do you
have a lot of canadian friends uh dc man
there's a lot of international schools
around
you know there's ways there's yeah quick
question
quick question okay tim and alex you
both
have been to dc and you know the dc area
right
yeah relative i've lived there a couple
years how you and you claim that there
are
diplomats children there right yeah how
can you prove
that you are not one of them right oh
that's a fair question
well i've i've lived there for 18 years
um and i didn't really live in somewhere
where diplomats live although i knew
them
because i feel like they're more
northwest uh and i was more like
central i guess like downtown uh near
georgetown yeah so i didn't actually
live in dc i i just my dad worked there
uh we lived in virginia so he would
commute up there a lot like most people
do we're about to in virginia like
arlington i'm guessing because right
now uh i actually lived in uh stafford
it's like right by fredericksburg if you
know what that is
oh yeah minutes away so yeah he would
commute up there so yeah
i had been in the dc air quite a bit we
only lived there for a few years
um let me move so i'm gonna vote out
alex
he was just trying to like prove himself
a little too much
that's all i think alex is pretty safe
on me i think mila is a little more
sus of me and alex i think the girls are
starting together i think the guys
deciding together what this is turning
into me
i i think i'm gonna go with mila i am
still most suspicious of alex
i don't know if that round went as well
as the last one i felt kind of attacked
yeah i'm gonna vote off mila because um
i
think what she's doing is deflecting
from her
the votes are in and we have a tie
[Music]
what the tie is between
alex and mila so you're gonna have 20
seconds to prove to us
why you're american okay okay this is
wild because i don't even care for being
an american but it is what it is
my family is generations from the same
area in california
literally from mississippi uh i don't
like i don't know what else to say this
is what it is
i was born and raised in america i
you know and that's time i was born in
dc
racing dc sibley hospital that's where
i'm born
uh i've got an american flag right there
but i cannot show you it i don't think
um i don't think you find many
libertarians outside of the us i think
it's
pretty pro you know american um and
i know a lot of international people
because my my parents worked for the
government that's why you've got
virginia
and new york coming together in dc baby
i feel like because i was on to them
they're threatened so now they're just
like let's vote her out
hopefully they've got my back and i um
and they won't vote me out
i'm an american i promise we gotta know
more about you other than your
libertarian who was born
in dc i don't i'm not really suspicious
of anybody
i know for a fact lynn's not gonna
change her answer on alex and
i don't want to do to alex and dirty
like that either
the votes are in and the person
eliminated
on round four is alex
uh it's a shame i'm not gonna get my
money mila's on her game though
gotta give her that give me a thumbs up
on zoom if you want to continue the game
if not you think you caught them all and
want to end the game
right now
[Music]
if the color that shows up behind me is
green
you all win if it's red the mole is
still in the game
and you lost yeah i'm sweaty
in three two
[Applause]
the mole can raise her hand and reveal
him or herself
in three two one
i knew him
[Laughter]
i voted for alex for like the past three
rounds
you were 100 right i'm not american
yeah no i believe it we got him
we got him oh my god that last round was
just so
important that tie if that tie had not
have happened
we would have lost i memorized the
pledge of allegiance i should have asked
someone to recite that
i shouldn't have switched my bow i'm
really upset i'll probably regret it
forever
the cast was pretty diverse they all had
really good perspectives there's a lot
that goes down in
what makes one american being willing to
share your culture
with others and also accepting of other
cultures that are different from yours
i love americans honestly i think it has
great principles great values
even though those values might not
necessarily be
in practice right now i think america is
the greatest but obviously not everyone
does
you know i sure felt american when we
won
i that's the only time i felt american
when we won
oh yeah that's the most american i ever
felt in my life